[Music]
let's talk about the movie in your
character it's a very funny idea for
movie it starts out your character is
like what 15 years old he isn't in 14th
pick somewhere in there he's a young kid
and he has an incredibly hot teacher and
they end up sleeping with each other I'm
just curious
the teacher the movies so hot did you
have a crush on your teacher when you
were kid is this based on anything in
your life no I mean I never got to close
the deal like that guy but first grade I
had a real crush on Miss calexis and and
my mom knew it and I just couldn't wait
to get to school all the time she's very
good-looking nice lady and she and my
mother used to make cupcakes and I'd
bring her a cupcake in like and my big
move with her was I wouldn't raised my
hand to go to the bathroom I would pee
myself how was that move here's how it
worked because then she had to change
[Laughter]
[Applause]
changing me I was like here we are
that's the smoothest move I've ever
heard of terrific cameos in this movie
yeah really nice he gets a hit people
pop Tony Orlando showed up I love 20 I
learned that Rex Ryan Rex Ryan Rex Ryan
was cool he he wanted to be in the movie
made a deal I made a deal with Rex two
times a year he's gonna let me
quarterback for the Jets you've been a
quarterback twice a year for the Jets I
chose the Patriots I'll play against the
Patriots just just I got to see Tom
Brady up close he's very good looking
[Laughter]
great we got a clip yeah we have a clip
what do we what do we need to know for
this clip this is this is I think it's
just were you're revealing a tattoo okay
yeah yeah yeah me I am thank you seeing
me and my my boy Andy Samberg you know I
was a bit of a drunken mess as a as a
dad and this is a scene that he's mad at
the Andy he's mad you weren't a great
dad and and he's trying to give you
evidence that you weren't a great dad
let's take a look at this clip from
that's my boy thank you Tony
sure you wear a bathing suit in the
shower you know that that's right
are you serious I can't even take my
shirt off in front of other people
because of you
well because of me what did I do it is
oh let me jog your memory
oh yes cuz I got it when I was in third
grade my body grew I'm sure it's fine oh
[Laughter]
you got it back too
[Applause]